(man) THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
COME SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS‐‐
FIVE POWERFUL SELF‐MADE
INVESTORS WORTH BILLIONS.
IN THE TANK, THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY...
YOU COULD BUILD
$100 MILLION BUSINESS.
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT BUSINESS.
ORDER IN THE NEXT TEN MINUTES,
AND WE'RE GONNA DOUBLE
YOUR ORDER.
BUT WAIT, THERE'S MORE.
THAT'S RIGHT. THERE IS MORE.
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
YOU NEED ME TO THINK BIG.
SHANE, GO AND CALL YOUR WIFE.
BARBARA, IF YOU SCREW
THIS UP FOR ME,
I'M GONNA SPANK YOU
LIKE A BABY SEAL.
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
(crying) THIS IS MY BABY,
YOU KNOW?
EVERYBODY WANTS BETTER
FOR THEIR FAMILY,
SO YOU GOTTA START SOMEWHERE.
I FEEL SO WARM AND FUZZY
I'M GONNA CRY.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN‐‐
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK‐FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
KEVIN HARRINGTON
IS THE KING OF INFOMERCIALS.
HIS GENIUS MARKETING
OF PRODUCTS
HAS AMASSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SALES.
DAYMOND JOHN TURNED
RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
THE SON OF A FACTORY WORKER
TURNED TECHNOLOGY MOGUL,
SOLD HIS FIRST
INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK IS
DEIDREA HAYSEL
WITH A PRODUCT SHE BELIEVES
WILL HELP EXPECTING MOMS
FEEL BEAUTIFUL.
♪♪♪
HEY.
MY NAME IS DEIDREA HAYSEL.
MY COMPANY IS HOT MAMA GOWNS,
AND I'M SEEKING $30,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
FOUR YEARS AGO, WHEN I GAVE
BIRTH TO MY FIRST CHILD,
IT SHOULD'VE BEEN THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL DAY OF MY LIFE,
BUT INSTEAD,
I HAVE TERRIBLE MEMORIES
OF FEELING HUMILIATED
AND INSECURE,
ALL BECAUSE I WAS WEARING
A NASTY, CHEMICAL‐SMELLING,
ILL‐FITTING HOSPITAL GOWN
THAT LEFT MY BODY EXPOSED.
I ACTUALLY HAD TO WEAR
TWO GOWNS‐‐ONE IN THE FRONT,
ONE IN THE BACK‐‐TO SOMEWHAT
COVER MY BACKSIDE.
I SWORE ON THAT DAY
FOUR YEARS AGO,
THAT NO WOMAN SHOULD EVER HAVE
TO FEEL HUMILIATED LIKE I DID
ON SUCH A JOYOUS DAY
IN HER LIFE,
SO I DESIGNED HOT MAMA GOWNS.
THEY'RE MADE OF 100% ORGANIC
COTTON, THEY'RE SUPER SOFT,
THEY HAVE SHORT SLEEVES FOR
I. V. s AND BLOOD PRESSURE CHECKS,
THEY HAVE A FULL SNAP‐DOWN BACK
TO KEEP MOM'S ASSETS COVERED,
AND THEY'RE DESIGNED
FOR BREAST‐FEEDING.
HOT MAMA GOWNS ALLOW MOM
TO FEEL BEAUTIFUL, CELEBRATED,
AND CONFIDENT.
SHE IS NOT
AN ILL HOSPITAL PATIENT.
SHE IS A BEAUTIFUL,
PREGNANT MOTHER,
AND WHAT SHE'S WEARING
SHOULD REFLECT THAT JOY,
AND THAT'S PRECISELY WHY
I DESIGNED HOT MAMA GOWNS.
NOW GIVE ME YOUR MONEY, OKAY?
(chuckles)
WHO CARES HOW YOU LOOK?
YOU JUST HAD A BABY. IT'S‐‐
IT'S NOT ABOUT HOW I LOOK.
IT'S‐‐IT'S ABOUT ME
AND BEING HUMILIATED
AMONG THESE TOTAL STRANGERS.
HOW MANY, UH, WOMEN
HAVE A BABY EVERY YEAR?
THIS IS WHY IT'S SO EXCITING.
IT'S A $4.5 BILLION MARKET‐‐
MATERNITY.
IT HAS EXPERIENCED 12% GROWTH
EVERY YEAR SINCE 2002.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
$11,500.
OVER WHAT PERIOD OF TIME?
THAT'S FROM 2009
TO CURRENTLY.
NOW YOU UNDERSTAND THAT ASKING
FOR $30,000 FOR 20%,
YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING YOUR
COMPANY IS WORTH $150,000?
ABSOLUTELY.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
I'M NOT STANDING IN FRONT OF YOU
WITH A SILVER SPOON IN MY MOUTH.
I'VE BEEN WORKING
SINCE I WAS 13 YEARS OLD.
I HAVE A FULL‐TIME JOB
WHILE I'M DOING THIS AT NIGHT,
AFTER THE KIDS GO TO BED, AFTER
I WORK MY 40‐HOUR A WEEK JOB.
WE VALUATE COMPANIES
ACCORDINGLY
TO HOW MUCH SALES YOU HAVE.
THERE'S NO DEBT
ON THIS COMPANY.
I HAVE NO LOANS.
I'VE NEVER BORROWED MONEY.
EVERYTHING IS PAID FOR.
I'M SITTING ON ABOUT
$20,000 OF FABRIC,
ALL THE CUSTOM‐MADE BOXES,
ALL THE BLANKETS ARE MADE SO‐‐
DEIDREA, WHAT DO YOU DO
FOR A REAL JOB?
I SELL DRUGS FOR A LIVING‐‐
THE LEGAL ONES.
I'M A PHARMACEUTICAL SALES REP.
I BET YOU DO
A GOOD JOB DOING THAT.
THANKS.
UM, I LIKE THIS DEAL,
I LIKE THE ENTHUSIASM,
BUT THOSE ARE BASIC INGREDIENTS
FOR ANY SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS.
LET'S FOCUS
ON HOW THIS BUSINESS GROWS.
AND I SAY TO YOU,
GET ME 10% OF THAT MARKET
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
HOW YOU GONNA DO THAT?
EASY. THIS IS M‐‐
THIS IS NO ADVERTISING.
NO ADVERTISING.
I HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING.
PEOPLE ARE COMING TO ME.
I HAVE RETAILERS CALLING ME,
WANTING TO CARRY MY GOWNS.
OH, REALLY?
ABSOLUTELY.
DEIDREA, YOU DIDN'T GIVE US
YOUR PRICE ON THIS.
MY PRICE POINT IS
A LITTLE BIT TOO HIGH.
WHY? BECAUSE I'M MANUFACTURING
IN SMALL QUANTITIES.
RETAIL PRICE‐‐THEY'RE $119.
AND KEEP IN MIND‐‐
$119?
YES, MA'AM.
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT, INCLUDING THE BOX?
UM, EVERYTHING ALL TOLD,
IT'S $49.
I JUST CAN'T GET OVER THIS‐‐
THE AMOUNT OF SALES.
YOU'RE ONLY DOING
$11,000 A YEAR IN SALES.
BUT IT'S JUST ME. THIS IS
ME WORKING A FULL‐TIME JOB.
I'D BE DANGEROUS IF I WAS
DOING THIS FULL‐TIME.
LET'S MAKE NO JOKE ABOUT THAT.
I'M NOT KIDDING.
YOU'RE SCARING ME NOW.
THIS IS ME FROM 10:00 AT NIGHT
TILL 2:00 IN THE MORNING
EVERY SINGLE NIGHT.
IS THIS TRUE?
WE HAVE A FIRECRACKER
SALES LADY. WE GOT A GREAT IDEA.
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE IS ANY
DISTRIBUTION. NOW WE GOT MR.‐‐
THAT'S WHAT I'M HERE FOR!
NOW WAIT A SECOND.
WE GOT A MR. CLOTHING GUY HERE.
WHAT'S THE STORY ON THIS,
DAYMOND?
WELL, HERE'S‐‐
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE‐‐
HOW DO YOU EDUCATE THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY THAT THIS EXISTS?
PREGNANCY'S NOT A TREND.
IT'S NOT A FAD.
IT'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
SO YOU'RE LOOKING
AT A $4.5 BILLION MARKET.
SO YOU'RE GETTING IN NOW
WITH A BRANDED PRODUCT
THAT PEOPLE KNOW, RESPECT,
AND THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING‐‐
THEY DON'T KNOW
AND RESPECT IT.
NOBODY KNOWS WHO YOU ARE,
DEIDREA.
HOW DO YOU KNOW? THEY DO.
YOU'RE DOING $11,000 A YEAR
IN SALES.
THIS IS BRAND‐NEW.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR 30K,
AND THAT WILL NOT EVEN GET YOU
PAST JUST PAYING YOURSELF.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT IT GETS ME
PAST. I NEED MORE INVENTORY.
SO THE NEXT TIME I GO
TO MY MANUFACTURER,
I'M GOING WITH BIGGER NUMBERS,
'CAUSE NOW I HAVE MONEY,
INSTEAD OF GOING "HERE'S
MY COUPLE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR A HUNDRED GOWNS."
BUT THERE'S SO MANY OTHER THINGS
NOT ADDRESSED.
BRING IT UP!
DEIDREA, YOU'RE‐‐YOU'RE
A FANTASTIC SALES REP,
BUT I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT'S MISSING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. BRING IT.
YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING HOW YOU'RE
GONNA GROW, HOW YOU'RE
GONNA ADVERTISE‐‐YOU DON'T KNOW
ANY OF THOSE COSTS.
OF COURSE I DO.
WELL, DEIDREA, HOW COULD YOU?
HOW COULD $30,000 PUT YOU
INTO ANY KIND OF A BRANDING/
ADVERTISING/MARKETING PROGRAM
ON A NATIONAL SCALE?
YOU KNOW,
LET ME TAKE A SHOT AT THIS.
I LIKE TO BRING CLARITY
TO THESE SITUATIONS.
(chuckles) BRING IT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
WITH THIS BUSINESS IS
ACTUALLY GETTING THE PRODUCT
TO THE CUSTOMER.
IT'S NOT, THOUGH.
EXCUSE ME. IN MY MIND,
AS AN INVESTOR,
YOU HAVE NOT IDENTIFIED THE COST
OF CUSTOMER ACQUISITION,
WHICH I BET IS BRUTAL.
EVERYBODY'S BEEN ASKING YOU,
PARTICULARLY ME,
WHAT DOES IT COST ME
TO GROW THE BUSINESS?
YOU CAN'T ANSWER THAT.
I'M N‐‐I'M NOT SURE
WHAT YOU WANT FROM ME,
BECAUSE I‐I HAVE ALL
THE ANSWERS. THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THIS IS NEW. IT'S NOT LIKE I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR FIVE YEARS.
IT'S A NEW IDEA.
WE'RE EDUCATING THE CUSTOMER.
RIGHT THERE‐‐
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED IT.
IT'S NOT A BUSINESS YET.
IT'S AN IDEA.
AND MAYBE IT'S A VERY GOOD IDEA,
BUT BETWEEN AN IDEA
AND A BUSINESS IS
ONE HELL OF A LONG ROAD.
I DON'T AGREE.
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THAT ROAD.
I DON'T WANT TO RIDE THAT ROAD
WITH YOU. I'M SORRY.
IT'S A GOOD ROAD.
(O'Leary) IT'S A LONG ROAD.
I'M OUT.
IS THERE NO WAY TO MAKE
THIS GOWN ONE SIZE FITS ALL?
THERE'S ACTUALLY
A GREAT POINT IN THAT.
THIS ISN'T A THROWAWAY GOWN
THAT YOU GO,
OH, I'M GIVE BIRTH INTO IT
AND THROW AWAY.
IT FITS A WOMAN BEFORE,
DURING, AND AFTER.
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO THE IDEA
OF MAKING A ONE SIZE FITS ALL?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE BENEFIT
OF THAT WOULD BE.
JUST FOR PRICE REASONS,
YOU WOULD SAY, TO GO ONE SIZE?
FOR PRICE REASONS, IT WOULD
MAKE AN ENORMOUS DIFFERENCE.
I'D HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT,
BECAUSE TO ME,
WHEN I THINK
"ONE SIZE FITS ALL,"
I THINK OF THE GOWN
THAT HER BOTTOM'S EXPOSED.
BECAUSE LIKE I SAID,
I'M SERVICING WOMEN
THAT ARE 2 TO 24, AND A 24‐SIZE
WOMAN‐‐THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
HAVE YOU EVER CONSIDERED
LICENSING THIS IDEA
TO THE GOWN COMPANIES?
I DIDN'T THINK
THAT IT WOULD BE WORTH IT,
BECAUSE THEY'RE LITERALLY
DOING THEM FOR 25 CENTS A GOWN,
AND THEY'RE NOT GONNA SEE‐‐THEY
WANT A ONE‐SIZE‐FITS‐ALL GOWN.
HERE'S THE ISSUE‐‐YOU KNOW,
IT'S WHAT YOU THINK
THAT YOU ALREADY KNOW
THAT WILL PREVENT YOU
FROM LEARNING.
IT'S TOO HIGH‐END.
I UNDERSTAND.
BUT YOU HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS,
SO YOU'LL NEVER LEARN FROM ME.
SO WITH THAT, I'M OUT.
THE PROBLEM I HAVE‐‐YOU WANT
YOUR CAKE AND EAT IT, TOO,
BECAUSE YOU'RE PART‐TIME,
BUT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR ME
TO PUT MY FULL‐TIME MONEY
INTO THIS DEAL.
I'M NOT, THOUGH.
IT'LL MAKE ME FULL‐TIME.
LIKE I SAID, I'M AMAZING. LIKE
I SAID, I COULD BE DANGEROUS...
AND SO HUMBLE.
IF I DO THIS. I'M A HOT MAMA.
I'M A HOT‐‐YEAH, SUPER WIFE.
MY HUSBAND'S GONE
MONDAY TO FRIDAY,
SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT SOMEBODY
THAT DOES EVERYTHING WITH
A 4 YEAR OLD AND 2 YEAR OLD,
WORKS A 40‐HOUR A WEEK JOB,
AND HUSTLES HER SIDE BUSINESS.
YOU CAN'T TAKE "NO" AS AN ANSWER
WHICH IS GREAT AS A SALES REP,
BUT YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING ANY
OF THE INVESTMENT QUESTIONS.
YOU'RE TOO SMALL.
LOOK AT YOURSELF IN THE MIRROR
AND MATURE TO A POINT WHERE
YOU CAN BE A BUSINESS OWNER,
NOT JUST A GREAT SALES REP.
I'M OUT.
(whispers) THANKS, ROBERT.
DEIDREA?
(normal voice) YES.
I HAVE TO SAY, I CAN'T GET OVER
THE PART‐TIME SITUATION.
THIS IS ALWAYS
GONNA BE MY HUSTLE.
I'M GONNA SAY I'M OUT.
SO IT'S‐‐IT'S BAD
THAT I HAVE A JOB?
IS THAT‐‐IS THAT WHAT IT IS?
THE BUSINESS IS NOT
GENERATING ENOUGH
FOR YOU TO PAY
FULL‐TIME ATTENTION,
SO WHY SHOULD HIS MONEY
PAY FULL‐TIME ATTENTION?
YEAH. IT'S TOO RISKY FOR ME.
THANK YOU.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA IS DEIDREA'S
LAST CHANCE TO MAKE A DEAL.
THAT LEAVES ME.
HI, BARBARA.
OH, DON'T GIVE ME
THAT LITTLE GIRL LOOK.
(laughs)
I'M OKAY WITH WHAT YOU SOLD
SO FAR WITH NO ADVERTISING,
BUT I AM VERY WORRIED
ABOUT YOU AS A PARTNER.
SO‐‐SO YOU MAKING AN OFFER
OUT OF ALL THIS?
BARBARA, I FORBID YOU
TO INVEST IN THIS BUSINESS.
I'M TIRED OF YOU KILLING MONEY.
♪♪♪
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
BARBARA CORCORAN IS DEIDREA'S
LAST CHANCE TO STRIKE A DEAL.
I'M OKAY WITH WHAT YOU SOLD
SO FAR WITH NO ADVERTISING,
BUT I AM VERY WORRIED
ABOUT YOU AS A PARTNER.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT
YOUR CLOSE‐MINDEDNESS,
BECAUSE ANY SUGGESTION
THAT'S BEEN MADE HERE,
I FEEL LIKE YOU BUTT AGAINST IT.
I'M JUST AFRAID OF THAT.
I APOLOGIZE IF IT COMES OFF
THE WAY IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S COMING OFF TO YOU GUYS,
'CAUSE THAT'S LITERALLY
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE
OF HOW I AM. I GUESS I WANTED
TO JUST PROVE TO YOU
THAT I GRIND, I WORK HARD,
LIKE, THIS IS‐‐THIS IS, LIKE,
MY EVERYDAY THING, YOU KNOW?
(crying) SO IT'S ACTUALLY
A LITTLE BIT‐‐
IT MAKES ME FEEL BAD THAT THAT'S
WHAT I'M PROJECTING TO YOU
OR THAT THAT'S HOW
IT'S COMING OUT,
'CAUSE THAT'S NOT
HOW I AM AT ALL.
I JUST WANT TO GET ACROSS
THAT THIS IS MY BABY, YOU KNOW?
EVERYBODY WANTS BETTER
FOR THEIR FAMILY,
SO YOU GOTTA START SOMEWHERE.
SORRY. (chuckles)
IT'S JUST‐‐I FELT LIKE
IT WAS A PERSONAL ATTACK,
AND THAT'S THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE
PERSON OF WHO I AM.
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU'RE IN LOVE
WITH SOMETHING
THAT'S NEVER
GONNA LOVE YOU BACK?
WAIT. WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
DEIDREA, LET ME PUT THIS
TO THE TEST, ALL RIGHT?
I'D BE INTERESTED
IN BUYING INTO YOUR BUSINESS.
(O'Leary)
JUST BECAUSE SHE'S CRYING?
NO, NOT AT ALL. NOT AT ALL.
BUT I AM CONCERNED, AGAIN,
ABOUT YOUR OPEN‐MINDEDNESS,
SO LET ME PUT WHAT THE PIECES
ARE ON THE TABLE.
ONE, I WOULD WANT YOU
TO BE TOTALLY OPEN
TO MAKING A CHEAPER GOWN...
I'M TOTALLY OPEN TO IT.
TOTALLY OPEN
TO MAYBE EVEN A BAG...
ABSOLUTELY. I HAVE PEOPLE
REQUEST THOSE.
TOTALLY OPEN TO MAYBE THREE
SIZES‐‐SMALL, MEDIUM, AND LARGE,
THAT SPAN A COUPLE OF SIZES,
EACH ONE.
I WOULD BE OPEN TO IT.
AND YOU MEAN IT?
AND TOTALLY OPEN
TO KEEPING YOUR DAY JOB
FOR THE NEXT HOWEVER MANY YEARS
BEFORE THIS BUSINESS COULD
AFFORD TO TAKE A DIME OUT,
WITHOUT COMPLAINING?
I'M NOT A COMPLAINER. (laughs)
GO BIG OR GO HOME.
THOSE ARE YOUR CONDITIONS,
BARBARA?
YEAH, THEY'RE THE CONDITIONS.
SO ARE YOU MAKING AN OFFER
OUT OF ALL THIS?
SO I'M MAKING AN OFFER
FOR $30,000
FOR 40% OF YOUR BUSINESS,
AND LET ME EXPLAIN WHY THE 40%.
BECAUSE THIS IS GONNA TAKE
A LOT OF MY TIME.
'CAUSE YOU HAVE TO
REINVENT YOUR PRODUCT,
YOU HAVE TO FIGURE AN ANGLE
TO MARKET THIS THING,
AND I WANT TO BE INTERESTED
ENOUGH IN IT TO PUT IN THE TIME.
BARBARA. BARBARA.
SHE SOLD A HUNDRED GOWNS.
THAT'S EIGHT GOWNS A MONTH.
I KNOW, BUT THAT'S A START.
EVERYBODY SITTING UP HERE
STARTED THERE.
DON'T KNOCK HER FOR THAT.
BARBARA, WHEN YOU DIE‐‐
WHEN YOU DIE AND GO TO HELL,
YOU'RE GONNA BE
SELLING MATERNITY GOWNS.
BUT YOU'LL LOOK GREAT.
(Barbara) OH, GOOD.
DO YOU ACCEPT HER OFFER?
40%'s TOO HIGH.
HA HA! SHE'S SAYING NO TO YOU!
WHOA!
I THINK THE OFFER'S GREAT,
BUT 40%'s TOO HIGH.
IT'S NOT A BAD THING.
I LOVE IT.
IT HAS TO BE MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL, AND IT'S‐‐
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU SAID NO.
'CAUSE IT'S NOT
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL.
BARBARA, YOU GOT CAUGHT.
NO, IT'S NOT A DIG
AGAINST HER AT ALL.
I‐I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU BRING
TO THE TABLE.
I'M OUT.
(mouths word)
I THINK WE'RE ALL OUT, DEIDREA.
OKAY. (sighs) THANKS, GUYS.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
SORRY FOR THE TEARS.
HUGE MISTAKE TO TURN THAT OFFER
DOWN, IN MY OPINION.
IT'S REALLY A SHAME THOUGH,
BECAUSE I COULD'VE
MADE THAT BUSINESS FLY.
I HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND.
I TURNED DOWN BARBARA BECAUSE
SHE HAD TOO MANY CONDITIONS
ON THE MONEY AND ON WHAT
SHE WANTED TO DO WITH THE BRAND.
SHE WANTED TO TAKE
THE SIZE RANGE AWAY,
WHICH IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO THE HOT MAMA GOWN,
BECAUSE IT'S SIZED TO FIT
BEFORE, DURING, AND AFTER BIRTH,
AND THAT JUST DIDN'T COINCIDE
WITH WHERE I SEE
THE BRAND GOING.
LAST SEASON,
WE SAW TIM AND ERIN
MAKE AN IMPASSIONED PLEA
TO THE SHARKS...
I PROMISE YOU, ROBERT,
I WILL NOT LET YOU DOWN.
I WILL MAKE GREASE MONKEY WIPES
BE A NATIONAL, FANTASTIC,
SUCCESSFUL BRAND.
WHICH LANDED THEM A $40,000
DEAL WITH ROBERT AND BARBARA.
WE WON'T LET YOU DOWN.
I PROMISE.
(Robert) GOOD JOB.
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
♪♪♪
I'M TIM STANSBURY.
AND I'M ERIN WHELAN,
AND WE'RE THE FOUNDERS
OF GREASE MONKEY WIPES.
GREASE MONKEY WIPES ARE
HEAVY DUTY, CITRUS‐BASED
CLEANING WIPES.
WE MADE A PROMISE
TO THE SHARKS
THAT WE WOULDN'T LET THEM DOWN,
AND WE'RE WORKING TIRELESSLY
TO MAKE THIS COMPANY
A SUCCESSFUL
INTERNATIONAL BRAND.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET
GREASE MONKEY WIPES
INTO PERFORMANCE BIKES,
THE LARGEST BICYCLE RETAILER
IN THE COUNTRY. WE'VE GONE FROM
BEING SOLD IN 40 RETAIL STORES
TO OVER 500.
AWESOME. LOOKS GREAT.
WE'VE SOLD OVER 200,000 UNITS,
AND OUR SALES HAVE INCREASED
OVER 700%.
ALL OF THIS IS DUE
TO THE INVESTMENT
THAT ROBERT AND BARBARA GAVE US,
AND THE EXPOSURE THAT
"SHARK TANK" HAS BROUGHT US.
WE'VE GONE FROM SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN A HOBBY
TO NOW IT'S
A FULL‐TIME BUSINESS.
IT'S MEANS WE'VE ARRIVED,
AND WE'RE HERE TO STAY.
♪♪♪
(Daymond) WHOO!
(woman laughs)
(exhales deeply) HELLO.
MY NAME IS BEN FOSSEY.
AND I'M MELISSA FOSSEY,
AND MY COMPANY IS CADDYSWAG.
WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO ASK FOR $60,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20%
OF OUR COMPANY.
NOW AS WE ALL KNOW, THERE'S TWO
TYPES OF GOLFERS IN THIS WORLD.
THERE'S THE SERIOUS GOLFER
AND THEN WHAT WE CALL
THE CADDYSWAG GOLFER.
THE CADDYSWAG GOLFER IS
YOUR AVERAGE, EVERYDAY GOLFER
WHOSE SCORE IS SECONDARY
TO JUST HAVING A GOOD TIME
ON THE COURSE.
THAT'S WHY I INVENTED
THE PAR‐6.
THE PAR‐6 IS DESIGNED TO FIT
INSIDE THE SHOE POCKET
OF ANY GOLF BAG.
THE PAR‐6 ALSO KEEPS
6 12‐OUNCE CANS COLD
FOR 18 HOLES GUARANTEED,
WITHOUT ICE.
HOW? EACH COOLER COMES
WITH A CUSTOMIZED
REFREEZABLE GEL PACK
WHICH IS GUARANTEED
TO KEEP THE CANS COLD.
NOW NOT ONLY DOES
THIS PAR‐6
PAY FOR ITSELF THE FIRST TIME
YOU USE IT, BUT IT CAN SAVE YOU
ANYWHERE FROM $20 TO $30
PER ROUND OF GOLF.
HOW? A GOLF COURSE SIX‐PACK
WILL COST YOU ANYWHERE FROM
ABOUT $25 TO $35 PLUS TIP.
A SIX‐PACK AT THE CORNER STORE
COSTS YOU ABOUT 5 OR 6 BUCKS.
SO BY KEEPING YOUR CANS COLD
WITH THE PAR‐6,
YOU'VE JUST SAVED $20 TO $30.
AND IF YOU CALL TODAY,
YOU CAN GET YOUR PAR‐6 COOLER
FOR JUST $19.99.
BUT WAIT.
ORDER IN THE NEXT TEN MINUTES,
AND WE'RE GONNA DOUBLE
YOUR ORDER‐‐
2 PAR‐6 COOLERS FOR $19.99,
PLUS SHIPPING AND HANDLING.
BUT WAIT, THERE'S MORE.
NO, THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE IS MORE.
WE'VE MADE THE VERY FIRST EVER
"SHARK TANK" VERSION
OF THE PAR‐6.
BEN, ARE THERE GOLF COURSES
THAT HAVE ANY RULES
ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO BRING YOUR OWN BEVERAGES?
THERE ARE SOME COURSES
THAT, YOU KNOW,
FROWN UPON YOU BRINGING
YOUR OWN ONTO THE COURSE,
BUT THERE'S ALSO A LOT
OF GOLF COURSES OUT THERE
THAT DON'T PROVIDE
ANY TYPE OF BEVERAGE SERVICE
AT ALL WHATSOEVER.
INTERESTING IDEA.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES RIGHT NOW?
WE'RE AVERAGING
$15,000 IN SALES A YEAR
SINCE WE'VE STARTED SO FAR,
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THAT'S
BY WORD OF MOUTH ONLY.
WE HAVE NOT INVESTED ANY MONEY
INTO ADVERTISING AT THIS TIME.
JUST SO THAT I DON'T CLUTTER
THE SPACE
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE WHO ARE
GOLF AFICIONADOS, I'M OUT.
I PLAY A LOT OF GOLF. THERE IS
NO GOLF COURSE OUT THERE
THAT'LL ALLOW YOU TO BRING YOUR
OWN BEVERAGE IN. YOU KNOW THAT.
I DISAGREE.
BUT YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S
CONSUMERS THAT ARE
CARRYING THEIR BEVERAGES
ON THE COURSE ALREADY.
AGREED. AND THEY USE‐‐
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THAT CONSUMER
SIMPLY TAKING A SMALL COOLER
AND PUTTING IT
IN THE BACK OF THE GOLF CART?
WELL, BECAUSE THEN YOU'RE
ADVERTISING THAT YOU HAVE
YOUR OWN BEVERAGES
ON THE‐‐ON THE GOLF CART.
WE'LL SHOW YOU WHAT OUR
CURRENT COMPETITION LOOKS LIKE,
AND THIS IS WHAT IT IS.
LIKE THIS.
AND IT'S A MESS. IT DOESN'T
STAY COLD FOR 18 HOLES.
IT LEAKS INSIDE THE‐‐INSIDE
THE POCKET OF YOUR GOLF BAG.
THIS WILL NOT DO THAT.
BEN, IF I GAVE YOU THE $60,000,
WHAT WOULD YOU USE IT FOR?
WE WOULD ORDER 10,000 UNITS
AT $3 APIECE.
WE'D TAKE THE REMAINDER
OF THE MONEY,
AND WE WOULD LOOK AT PUTTING
AN ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN
TOGETHER IN TARGETED MARKETS,
TO BE ABLE
TO TURN THE PRODUCT OVER.
WE'RE SELLING 'EM RIGHT NOW
FOR 2 FOR $19.99.
THAT'S A PROFIT MARGIN
OF $13.99.
NOW I'M NO MATH MAJOR,
BUT I'M PRETTY SURE AT $13.99,
YOU ONLY HAVE TO GET 71,500
ORDERS TO GROSS $1 MILLION.
THERE'S OVER 36 MILLION GOLFERS
IN THE UNITED STATES ALONE.
BEN, I'M NO MATH MAJOR EITHER,
BUT $15,000 IN SALES PER YEAR
IS PRETTY CLOSE TO ZERO.
IT'S BASICALLY A COOLER BAG,
AND THERE'S A HUGE MARKET
OF DEVICES
THAT COOL ALL KINDS OF THINGS.
(Robert) YEAH.
MY KIDS HAVE COOLERS LIKE THIS
WITH EXACTLY THE SAME THING,
IN DIFFERENT SHAPES.
LIKE, I THINK IF SOMEONE IS
REALLY MOTIVATED TO BRING
BEVERAGES ONTO THE GOLF COURSE,
THEY REALLY DON'T NEED YOUR BAG.
THERE'S A MILLION DIFFERENT USES
THAT YOU CAN USE THIS FOR.
YOU GOTTA REMEMBER
THE PROMOTIONAL MARKET AS WELL.
WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT IT?
WHAT'S PATENTABLE? WHAT'S‐‐
WHAT MAKES THIS COOLER BETTER
THAN THE THOUSAND OTHER COOLERS
MY WIFE AND KIDS BUY?
ONE, WE'VE‐‐WE'VE CHANGED
THE CORNER ON IT
WHERE THE ZIPPER ATTACHES
TO THE COOLER ITSELF,
TO PREVENT ANY LEAKING
IF YOU WERE TO USE IT FOR ICE,
AND THAT IS WHAT DOES
MAKE IT PATENTABLE.
BUT THERE ARE COOLERS THAT
DON'T NEED ICE. YOU KNOW THAT.
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT THEY'RE NOT SHAPED
IN THIS‐‐THEY'RE NOT SHAPED
IN THIS FASHION.
SO AGAIN, THE‐‐THE ONLY THING
THAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT THIS IS
THE SHAPE OF THE COOLER?
AND THE CORNER, AS HE JUST
EXPLAINED‐‐IT DOESN'T LEAK ICE.
AND THE FUNCTIONALITY. IT FITS
IN EVERY SINGLE GOLF BAG,
OR YOUR MONEY BACK.
WOULDN'T YOU AGREE
THE BEST PLACE TO ADVERTISE THIS
IS THE GOLF CHANNEL?
ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY, THEN I'M GONNA TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW, ON THE GOLF CHANNEL,
MOST PRODUCTS ARE GONNA GIVE YOU
A LOWER SCORE.
RIGHT.
OKAY? THIS IS A PRODUCT THAT'S
KIND OF A FRIVOLOUS‐TYPE PRODUCT
THAT IT, YOU KNOW, IT, TO ME, IT
DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH PUNCH TO IT
TO REALLY GET THE PHONE
TO RING.
SO I'M OUT.
(Robert) I THINK
IT'S A TRIVIAL PRODUCT.
I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GONNA SELL VERY MANY.
I THINK YOU HAVE
AN UPHILL BATTLE.
IT SOLVES A NEED...
YEAH.
IT PAYS FOR ITSELF
THE FIRST TIME YOU USE IT,
AND IT SAVES GOLFERS MONEY
EVERY TIME MOVING FORWARD.
I'M OUT.
I THINK THERE IS A NEED
FOR THE PRODUCT.
I HAVE TWO BROTHERS,
BOTH ROOFERS,
THAT CONSISTENTLY SNEAK BEER
ONTO THE GOLF COURSE,
AND THEY PROBABLY NEED
FOUR OR FIVE OF THESE
'CAUSE THEY DRINK A TON.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
(Melissa) RIGHT.
BUT IT'S STILL A SMALL BUSINESS.
IT'S NOT THE KIND OF BUSINESS
THAT YOU GET AN INVESTOR
TO PUT THEIR MONEY IN,
'CAUSE YOU JUST COULDN'T GET
THE MONEY BACK OUT.
IT WOULD TAKE TOO DARN LONG.
SO I'M OUT.
YOU'RE MAKING SOMETHING
THAT ALREADY EXISTS ALREADY IN
A THOUSAND DIFFERENT ITERATIONS.
THERE'S NOTHING TO INVEST IN.
AND I'M VERY DEPRESSED NOW,
BECAUSE I KNOW WITH CERTAINTY
THERE'S NO CHANCE
THAT I CAN EVER MAKE ANY MONEY
WITH YOU.
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION‐‐
WHEN YOU GO OUT
ON THE GOLF COURSE, DO YOU WANNA
PAY $6 FOR A‐‐FOR ONE COLD BEER
OR DO YOU WANT TO BE ABLE
TO GET A SIX‐PACK?
(laughs)
YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING ME.
I MEAN, HEY, L‐LET'S FACE IT‐‐
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
THE MOST MONEY ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE WATCHING THE BOTTOM DOLLAR.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT DO NOT
WANT TO SPEND THE MONEY
THAT'S OUT ON THE GOLF COURSE‐‐
BEN, SERIOUSLY, YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA CREATE
A MULTIMILLION DOLLAR BUSINESS
BY SAVING PEOPLE
A COUPLE OF BUCKS ON A BEER
WHEN THEY GO GOLFING?
I THINK THAT WE CAN SELL
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF THESE‐‐OF THESE UNITS
AND MAKE MONEY ON IT AND MAKE
MONEY FOR YOU GUYS AS WELL.
I'M OUT.
WELL,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
DO WE GET OUR COOLERS BACK THEN
SINCE YOU DON'T WANT 'EM?
OKAY, WELL, I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND LET YOU GUYS
KEEP PAYING FOR ALL
OF YOUR BEVERAGES ON THE COURSE.
GOOD LUCK. GOOD LUCK, MY MAN.
I'VE GOTTA GO MAKE
SOME MONEY ON THESE.
THANK YOU.
NICE MEETING YOU ALL.
WOW.
THAT WAS HORRIFIC. THAT WAS
AN ABSOLUTE HORRIFIC IDEA.
WHY‐‐WHY DID YOU PISS HIM OFF?
HE TOOK AWAY MY COOLER.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN BUY ONE
FOR $19.95.
THAT WAS SUCH A BAD IDEA.
THOSE GUYS HAVE TOO MUCH MONEY.
I MEAN, THEY DON'T GET
WHAT THE AVERAGE CONSUMER'S
GOING THROUGH,
ESPECIALLY IN THIS ECONOMY.
PEOPLE WANT TO SAVE MONEY,
AND PEOPLE ARE SNEAKING BEER
ON THE COURSE.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THEY SAY.
♪♪♪
I'M KIM NELSON, I'M FROM
SPARTANBURG, SOUTH CAROLINA,
AND MY COMPANY IS DAISY CAKES.
MY CAKES ARE
MY GREAT AUNT DAISY'S
AND MY GRANDMOTHER'S RECIPES,
PASSED DOWN BY GENERATIONS
OF ALL THE WOMEN IN OUR FAMILY.
WE USE ONLY FRESH,
NATURAL INGREDIENTS,
AND THERE'S LOTS
OF SOUTHERN LOVE IN EVERY BITE.
WE PACKAGE 'EM
IN THESE BEAUTIFUL TINS,
AND WE SHIP THEM NATIONWIDE,
RIGHT TO YOUR DOOR.
(horn honks)
HEY!
THANK YOU.
MY MAMA GERALDINE AND I
BAKE EVERY SINGLE CAKE
THAT COMES OUT OF THAT KITCHEN,
AND WE ARE
TWO OF THE HARDEST WORKING WOMEN
YOU WILL EVER MEET,
BUT WE NEED SOME HELP. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO MEET THE DEMAND.
MY FAMILY'S INVESTED $93,000
IN THIS BUSINESS,
AND THERE'S NO MORE MONEY
TO PUT IN,
SO I REALLY NEED HELP
FROM THE SHARKS.
I NEED AN INVESTMENT.
I PUT SO MUCH LOVE AND SO MUCH
PASSION INTO THE CAKES I MAKE,
AND I HOPE
THEY WILL SEE THAT
AND THAT THEY'LL WANT
A PIECE OF IT.
♪♪♪
HEY.
I AM SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
IT'S SO NICE TO MEET Y'ALL.
MY NAME IS KIM NELSON,
AND I'M FORM SPARTANBURG,
SOUTH CAROLINA,
AND MY COMPANY IS DAISY CAKES.
I'M ASKING FOR $50,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 25% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
MY DAISY CAKES ARE
THE BEST CAKES
THAT YOU WILL EVER PUT
IN YOUR MOUTH.
THEY ARE MY FAMILY RECIPES.
THEY ARE MADE FROM SCRATCH.
WE DON'T USE ANY PRESERVATIVES,
ARTIFICIAL FLAVORS IN OUR CAKES.
AND THE BEST PART‐‐
WE DELIVER THEM TO YOU.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU
TO TASTE THEM.
MMM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE CHOCOLATE.
OH, OKAY.
OH, WOW.
(Robert) WOW, IS THAT EVER GOOD.
THAT LOOKS VERY GOOD.
WOW!
(Harrington) MMM.
SO THE CARROT CAKE‐‐
MY NUMBER ONE SELLER.
FANTASTIC, BY THE WAY.
THANK YOU. WE PUT A WHOLE POUND
OF CARROTS IN EVERY CAKE...
MMM.
ALSO SOME GOLDEN RAISINS
AND JUST A HINT OF CINNAMON...
(Barbara) MMM.
AND THEN A DELICIOUS
CREAM CHEESE ICING.
RED VELVET CAKE‐‐
THE SOUTHERN HOLIDAY TRADITION.
OF COURSE.
AND THEN KEVIN,
YOU HAD THE LEMON BURST.
(Harrington) LEMON.
THAT'S MY NEWEST CAKE,
AND IT'S CREAM CHEESE ICING.
BUT IT HAS
A FRESH LEMON CURD IN IT.
SO WE HAND ZEST
AND JUICE THE LEMONS,
WE USE CAGE‐FREE EGGS
AND SUGAR‐‐THAT'S IT.
HOW DO YOU GET 'EM OUT
TO THE CUSTOMERS?
SO YOU WOULD CALL ME
OR GO ON MY WEB SITE,
AND THEN I SHIP THEM NATIONWIDE.
AND, UH, WE PACK 'EM WITH
DRY ICE, SO THEY'RE FROZEN.
AND THEN YOU CAN TAKE IT OUT
AND ENJOY A LITTLE BIT AT A TIME
IF YOU WANT TO, OR YOU CAN HAVE
THE WHOLE CAKE AT ONCE
IF YOU NEED IT FOR AN EVENT.
WHAT DO YOU SELL
THESE CAKES FOR?
UM, ONLINE THEY'RE $44.50.
SO THEY'RE PRETTY PRICY.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE?
$18.
HOW DID YOU GET INVOLVED
IN THE CAKE BUSINESS?
WELL, HONESTLY, IT IS‐‐IT IS
MY GOD‐GIVEN TALENT
FROM HAVING, UM, DONE CATERING
AND TAUGHT COOKING CLASSES.
SO I DECIDED TO JUST START
THE COMPANY, AND...
SO, KIM,
THE CAKES ARE FANTASTIC.
BEST CAKES I'VE TASTED. UH...
(Barbara) BEST CAKE
I'VE EVER HAD, REALLY.
(Robert) YEAH.
THANK YOU.
HEY, KIM, BUT HOW DO YOU‐‐
HOW DO YOU GET THE CUSTOMERS?
WELL, THE BEST WAY TO GET
THE CUSTOMERS IS TO GO
TO THE SHOWS. YOU HAVE A BOOTH,
AND THEY GET TO COME BY.
MY MOTHER CUTS EVERY ONE OF THEM
INTO THESE LITTLE TINY SQUARES
SO THAT YOU COME BY AND YOU GET
TO HAVE IT ON A TOOTHPICK.
WHAT TYPE OF SHOW
ARE YOU SPEAKING ABOUT?
OH, LIKE JUNIOR LEAGUE SHOWS.
THEIR HOLIDAY SHOWS.
LIKE FOR LITTLE COMMUNITIES?
(Daymond) SO THIS IS
TO GET DISTRIBUTORS?
UM, OH, NO. NOT, UH‐‐MNH‐MNH.
NOT A WHOLESALE.
THIS IS, UM, LIKE FUND‐RAISERS,
LIKE JUNIOR LEAGUE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WE JUST FINISHED OUR FIRST YEAR,
AND OUR SALES HAVE BEEN GREAT
WITH PEOPLE IN THE SOUTH,
WHERE WE'VE GONE.
WE NEED A NUMBER, KIM.
HOW MUCH HAVE
YOUR SALES BEEN?
UM, THE THREE MONTHS
OF OCTOBER, NOVEMBER,
AND DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR‐‐
$27‐‐$27,000.
A LITTLE OVER $27,000.
IN 3 MONTHS?
IN THREE MONTHS, YES.
AND HOW MANY SHOWS DID
YOU AND YOUR MOM ATTEND
TO SELL THAT?
THREE.
THREE. IN YOUR LOCAL AREA?
WELL, NO.
I'M FROM SOUTH CAROLINA,
BUT WE WENT TO, UM, BATON ROUGE
AND LAFAYETTE, LOUISIANA,
AND THEN TO HOUSTON, TEXAS.
SO SHORT OF PUTTING YOU
AND YOUR MOM IN A CAR
WITH A BUNCH OF CAKES
AND TRAVELING THE COUNTRY...
RIGHT.
HOW ARE WE GONNA SELL THESE?
WELL, HOPEFULLY,
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO GET ON, UM,
ONE OF THE SHOPPING NETWORKS.
OKAY, LET'S JUST SAY THAT
FOR A SECOND.
LET'S SAY I PUT YOU
ON THE SHOPPING NETWORK‐‐
I CAN DO THAT‐‐AND I GET YOU
100,000 ORDERS FOR CAKES.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
KILL YOUR MOTHER TO MAKE THEM?
HOW YOU GONNA DO THAT?
WELL, WE WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE TO DO
A LITTLE DIFFERENT, UM,
WAY OF BAKING.
WHERE DO YOU MAKE 'EM NOW?
WE‐‐I HAVE
A COMMERCIAL KITCHEN.
WELL, COULD YOU MAKE 5,000
IN A WEEK?
OR WHAT KIND OF QUANTITIES
CAN YOU HANDLE?
I CAN MAKE 5,000 IN 30 DAYS.
SO UNLESS YOU HAVE PERSONALLY
ENGAGED THE CONSUMER,
YOU HAVE NOT MADE ANY SALES
TO A GROCERY STORE...
MM‐HMM. LET ME TELL YOU.
SOMEBODY WHO HAS NO IDEA
WHO YOU ARE‐‐
YOU HAVE NOT MADE SALES
IN THAT AREA YET?
UM, OKAY,
SO THIS IS MY LEMON CURD.
I'M IN THE PROCESS OF HAVING
MY LEMON CURD PICKED UP
TO BE CARRIED AT WHOLE FOODS.
OKAY.
AND HOW ARE YOU GONNA PRODUCE
ENOUGH QUANTITY FOR THEM,
ASSUMING THEY DO A ROLL‐OUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
UM, I'M GONNA NEED YOUR HELP.
HEY, KIM...
YES.
I GET DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
CATALOGS, UH, A MONTH, AND I SEE
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE SELLING
THIS KIND OF PRODUCT‐‐CAKES
AND PIES AND‐‐AND CHEESECAKES
AND ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF,
SO IT'S VERY COMPETITIVE.
IF YOU CAN GET THAT PRODUCT
IN THEIR MOUTHS AND LET THEM
TASTE IT OR GET, YOU KNOW,
GET SOMEBODY LIKE YOU
TO SAY HOW GOOD IT IS‐‐
SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE
A VERY SMALL REGIONAL STRATEGY
THAT'S WORKING FOR YOU.
MM‐HMM.
I MEAN, $27,000
IN 3 MONTHS ISN'T BAD.
WHY CAN'T YOU AND YOUR MOM
HOP IN THE CAR, TAKE THE CAKES‐‐
I'M ASSUMING THESE ARE
YOUR MOM'S RECIPES.
MY‐‐THEY'RE MY‐‐ACTUALLY,
YEAH, FAMILY RECIPES.
MY GRANDMOTHER'S.
DAISY WAS MY GREAT AUNT.
WHY CAN'T YOU CONTINUE
TO DO THAT?
JUST GO TO THESE TRADE SHOWS
AND SELL THEM THAT WAY.
BECAUSE I WANT IT TO BE
A HUGE BUSINESS.
I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
HOW FABULOUS MY CAKES ARE.
WHEN THEY THINK OF ORDERING
SOMETHING, THEY DON'T WANT
TO ORDER FLOWERS, THEY DON'T
WANT TO ORDER FRUIT.
THEY'RE THINKING, OH, MY GOSH.
I'M SENDING A CAKE.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM. THE‐‐THEY
ARE THE BEST I'VE EVER TRIED,
BUT TO TURN THAT INTO A BUSINESS
IS A HUGE CHALLENGE,
AND ONE THAT I'M NOT PREPARED
TO TAKE. I'M OUT.
(whispers) OKAY.
KIM, I SEE THIS
AS A WORD‐OF‐MOUTH TYPE
OF BUSINESS,
AND I LOOK FOR FAST GROWTH.
THANK YOU FOR A GREAT
EXPERIENCE, UH, TASTEWISE,
BUT I'M OUT TODAY.
SO 85% OF BUSINESSES IN AMERICA
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT DO NOTHING BUT PROVIDE
A LIVING FOR THE OWNER,
BUT THAT'S NOT
AN INVESTABLE BUSINESS.
I WISH YOU ALL THE SUCCESS.
I WILL BE A CUSTOMER,
BUT THERE'S REALLY NOTHING
TO INVEST IN TODAY. I'M OUT.
(mouths word)
KIM, I THINK THE BUSINESS IS
TOO SMALL FOR ME, SO I'M OUT.
EVERYBODY'S OUT HERE
EXCEPT BARBARA.
SO WHAT ARE WE DOING,
BARBARA?
I LIKE YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK IT'S TOO SMALL
A BUSINESS,
QUITE HONESTLY, TO INVEST IN.
(mouths word)
HOWEVER...
I NOTICED WHEN YOU PASSED
YOUR DELICIOUS CAKE AROUND,
EVERY GUY HERE ATE
MORE THAN 50% AND‐‐
THAT DOESN'T MEAN
IT'S A GOOD INVESTMENT, BARBARA.
BUT AFTER EACH OF THESE GUYS
DROPPED OUT,
THEY'VE BENT FORWARD, I NOTICED,
AND HAD ANOTHER BITE.
SO I'M GONNA TAKE A FLIER
ON THIS, BUT I AM WORRIED
ABOUT MY GETTING MY MONEY OUT
OF A TINY LITTLE BUSINESS,
SO HERE ARE THE TWO CONDITIONS‐‐
FOR EVERY CAKE SOLD,
YOU MAIL ME $1.
SO BY THE TIME
YOU SELL 50,000 CAKES,
I'D HAVE MY MONEY BACK. OKAY?
YES, MA'AM.
AND SECONDLY, THAT YOU MAKE SURE
YOUR MOTHER'S ON YOUR TEAM
AND SHE'S GONNA BE HUSTLING
THESE CAKES AT EVERY TRADE SHOW,
AND THE MONEY'S GONNA BE USED
FOR TRADE SHOWS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
(exhales deeply) OF COURSE.
YES, MA'AM.
OOH!
GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. (laughs)
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
(laughs)
(Robert) THANK YOU.
BYE.
YOU KNOW, BARBARA, YOU'RE
ONE CRAZY CHICK, YOU KNOW?
I'M NOT AT ALL.
I'M GONNA GET MY MONEY BACK.
THIS GIRL'S A HUSTLER.
YOU KNOW WHO SHE REMINDS ME OF?
MY ELEPHANT LADY.
SHE CAME THROUGH 150%, AND SHE'S
CUT OUT OF THE SAME CLOTH.
EVERY CAKE I SELL,
I'M GONNA BE THINKING OF BARBARA
AND THANKING BARBARA,
BECAUSE SHE HAS MADE ALL THIS
REALLY, REALLY COME TO FRUITION,
AND IT IS GONNA MAKE
SUCH A BIG DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE MY BUSINESS IS
GOING TO SKYROCKET.
♪♪♪
MY NAME'S SHANE PANNELL.
I'M FROM MARICOPA, ARIZONA.
WHO'S READY TO EAT?
I AM.
I'M A STAY‐AT‐HOME DAD,
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHAT.
IT IS VERY, VERY CHALLENGING.
♪♪♪
(crying)
WITH A 9 YEAR OLD, A 4 YEAR OLD
AND A 2 YEAR OLD,
THE LIST OF CHORES ARE ENDLESS.
♪♪♪
IN FACT, I DON'T KNOW
HOW WOMEN CAN DO IT.
BUT FORTUNATELY FOR ME,
ALL THAT CLEANING HAS LED
TO WHAT I BELIEVE IS
A BRILLIANT IDEA.
I'VE CREATED A TOOL
TO HELP PEOPLE CLEAN
THEIR FLOORS LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
AS A STAY‐AT‐HOME DAD,
THERE'S NOT A WHOLE LOT MORE
I CAN DO FROM HOME
TO HELP ADVANCE MY PRODUCT,
SO I NEED THE SHARKS. I REALLY
HOPE THE SHARKS LOVE MY PRODUCT.
OTHERWISE I'M GONNA HAVE TO
GIVE UP ON THIS DREAM
OF GETTING MY PRODUCT
OUT THERE ON THE MARKET.
♪♪♪
HI.
MY NAME IS SHANE PANNELL.
THE NAME OF MY COMPANY IS
SweepEasy.
I'M SEEKING
A $40,000 INVESTMENT
FOR 25% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
NOW FOR CENTURIES,
THE COMMON HOUSE BROOM
HAS BEEN A TRUSTED TOOL TO HELP
PEOPLE CLEAN THEIR FLOORS,
BUT IT'S ONLY BEEN GOOD FOR ONE
THING, AND THAT'S SWEEPING.
AND IT FALLS SHORT WHEN IT COMES
TO SOLVING THE COMMON PROBLEM
THAT EVERYBODY IN THE WORLD
HAS‐‐
HOW DO YOU GET RID OF THINGS
THAT ARE STUCK ON YOUR FLOORS
THAT JUST WON'T COME UP?
WELL, THAT PROBLEM HAS NOW BEEN
SOLVED, BECAUSE WITH MY PRODUCT,
THE SweepEasy
SCRAPE AND GO BROOM,
YOU NOT ONLY HAVE A GREAT BROOM,
BUT WITH THE PUSH OF A HANDLE,
NOW YOU'VE GOT
A BUILT‐IN SCRAPER.
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
WHEN SOMEONE COMES ACROSS
SOMETHING LIKE
THIS DRIED‐UP OATMEAL OR YOGURT
OR CEREAL ON THE FLOOR,
YOU SIMPLY SCRAPE, SWEEP,
AND GO.
YOU HAVE DRIED‐UP SPAGHETTI
OR MAC AND CHEESE,
ELIMINATE IT WITH EASE.
SIMPLY SCRAPE, SWEEP, AND GO.
SHANE,
YOU HAVE A PATENT ON THAT?
I DO. IT'S PATENT PENDING
RIGHT NOW.
SHANE, WHERE ARE YOU
SELLING THIS CURRENTLY?
I'M NOT CUR‐‐CERT‐‐
CURRENTLY SELLING IT.
I HAVEN'T SOLD ANY YET,
BUT THAT'S ONLY BECAUSE
I'M WORKING WITH PROTOTYPES.
THESE ARE PROTOTYPES
THAT I MADE MYSELF.
WHERE DID THIS HIT YOU?
DID YOU HAVE A DREAM
ABOUT SCRAPING CRAP
OFF THE FLOOR?
I BECAME A STAY‐AT‐HOME DAD
NOT TOO LONG AGO,
AND I FOUND THAT IS
ONE TOUGH JOB.
THANKS TO MY THREE KIDS
AND MY MOTHER‐IN‐LAW,
I WAS ALWAYS FINDING THIS
ON THE FLOOR‐‐BAND‐AIDS,
STICKERS, TAPE, GLUE,
YOU NAME IT.
AND ONE DAY I WAS
AT MY HANDS AND KNEES,
AND I'M, LIKE, SCRAPING UP
OATMEAL WITH A BUTTER KNIFE.
AND I THOUGHT, YOU KNOW WHAT,
SHANE? WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THERE'S GOTTA BE A BETTER WAY
TO GET RID OF THIS. AND BAM!
SHANE, CAN I TRY?
SO LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
ROBERT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YEAH.
I WANT TO HAVE YOU COME DOWN
BECAUSE YOU'RE
MY WIFE'S FAVORITE.
SHE LIKES YOUR EYES.
YOU KNOW, SHANE,
I'M THE ONLY GUY HERE
WHO HAS ACTUALLY EVER SWEPT
A FLOOR, I BET.
I WAS A STAY‐AT‐HOME DAD
FOR THREE YEARS.
THERE YOU GO. LOOK AT
THAT MACARONI AND CHEESE.
DISAPPEARS WITH EASE.
SEAN, HAVE YOU SHOWN THIS
TO ANY RETAILERS?
I HAVE.
AND WHAT RESPONSE DID YOU GET?
I'VE HEARD THINGS LIKE "MARKET
MOVER," AND‐‐AND THE FACT
THAT IT BLOWS PEOPLE AWAY.
I'VE TALKED WITH
ONE OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST
JANITORIAL SUPPLIES COMPANIES,
AND THEIR QUESTION TO ME WASN'T
WHETHER OR NOT I HAD A PRODUCT.
THEY SAID, "SHANE, WHEN CAN YOU
HAVE A FINISHED PRODUCT?"
DID THEY GIVE YOU
A PURCHASE ORDER?
THEY DIDN'T GIVE ME
A PURCHASE ORDER YET
BECAUSE I'M NOT LICENSED,
BONDED, INSURED.
I'M A‐‐I'M JUST
A ONE‐MAN COMPANY RIGHT NOW.
I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND YOUR VISION
FOR THIS BUSINESS.
OKAY.
ARE WE GONNA MAKE BROOMS
AND START SELLING 'EM
TO ALL KINDS OF STORES
OR ARE WE GONNA GO AND TRY TO GO
TO BIG BROOM COMPANIES
AND SELL THEM OUR BROOMS
SO THEY CAN MAKE IT?
EXACTLY. ALL THE ABOVE.
BUT, SHANE, WHY CAN'T WE GO TO
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY MAKE BROOMS
AND GET 'EM TO SIMPLY USE THIS
WITHIN THEIR PRODUCTS?
(Daymond) YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LICENSE?
YEAH.
WELL,
I THOUGHT OF LICENSING.
WELL, I THINK YOU CAN DO THAT,
ROBERT, YOU CAN DO THAT,
BUT THE REAL MONEY‐‐IF YOU CAN
SELL IT DIRECT TO THE CONSUMER,
YOU COULD BUILD
$100 MILLION‐DOLLAR BUSINESS.
(O'Leary) ON A SINGLE PRODUCT?
OH, SURE.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RETAIL THIS AT?
I'D BEAT THE PAVEMENT
AT RESTAURANTS, MOVIE THEATERS,
HOSPITALS, SCHOOLS‐‐EVERYWHERE
I'VE GONE, AND I'LL ASK THEM,
"WHAT WOULD YOU PAY
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS?"
AND THE ANSWER IS
ALWAYS THE SAME‐‐$19.95.
THAT'S WONDERFUL. LET'S TALK
ABOUT MONEY, MY FRIEND.
I DON'T WANT TO BE
IN THE BUSINESS
OF MANUFACTURING BROOMS
WHEN I CAN GO AND GET THAT
DISTRIBUTION ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND JUST SIT THERE
AND COLLECT THE CHECK.
THAT'S MY IDEA
OF A GREAT BUSINESS,
AND I'D LIKE TO DO THAT WITH
YOU. I'M GONNA START RIGHT NOW.
$40,000 FOR 20%‐‐
YOU GOT IT, KID.
(Harrington) I WOULDN'T EVEN
THINK ABOUT THAT OFFER YET.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT JUST
LICENSING THIS PRODUCT, OKAY?
THAT'S ABOUT 30% TO 40%
OF THE INCOME THAT YOU CAN MAKE
AT THE END OF THE DAY
ON THIS PRODUCT.
I THINK YOU NEED TO EXPLORE
NOT ONLY LICENSING,
BUT DIRECT TO THE CONSUMER,
OKAY, AND THAT'S MY EXPERIENCE,
AND I THINK, UM,
I AM INTERESTED.
OKAY, $50,000 FOR 20%.
$50,000 FOR 20%.
STOP LISTENING TO THESE GUYS,
'CAUSE BY THE WAY, I COULD GET
ANOTHER TELEVISION GUY.
WE DON'T NEED THIS
TELEVISION‐‐TELEVISION GUY.
THERE'S LOTS OF TELEVISION GUYS.
I'M THE BEST, THOUGH.
I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW
THE STRATEGY THAT'S GONNA
MAKE YOU FILTHY RICH.
AND TO DO THAT, WE'RE GOING
TO A LICENSE STRATEGY.
SO I'M STARTING YOU RIGHT NOW.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $50,000
FOR 20% 'CAUSE I'M NOT GREEDY.
A SMALL PIECE FOR ME, I'M HAPPY.
I'LL MAKE THIS HAPPEN FOR YOU.
A COUPLE OF PHONE CALLS,
WE'RE DONE.
SHANE, WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT
LICENSING THIS
ALL OVER THE WORLD,
I DO THAT, TOO. OKAY?
WHAT I DO THOUGH IS, FIRST I DO
THE TV COMMERCIAL HERE.
THEN WE LICENSE THAT
ALL OVER THE WORLD, OKAY?
SO IT'S A LOT EASIER
TO MAKE THAT PHONE CALL
TO INDIA AND TO BRAZIL
WHEN WE HAVE A TV COMMERCIAL
THAT HAS WORKED HERE
IN THE U. S.
THAT WE CAN THEN GIVE TO THEM TO
ROLL OUT IN THAT LOCAL MARKET.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I THINK‐‐I THINK
THE BIGGER PROBLEM HERE, SHANE,
IS THAT YOU WANT TO RUN
YOUR OWN COMPANY. CORRECT?
SURE. WITH‐‐WITH...
'CAUSE YOU SAID YOU WANT
TO MAKE PRODUCT.
WITH SOMEONE WITH SOME BUSINESS
SAVVY LIKE YOURSELVES.
LIKE‐‐LIKE, ME, YES.
L‐LIKE YOU.
BUT YOU WANT TO RUN
YOUR OWN COMPANY
AND POTENTIALLY GROW SweepEasy,
COME UP WITH OTHER PATENTS,
AND HAVE A COMPANY.
DAYMOND, CLOTHING GUY‐‐WHAT DO
YOU HAVE TO DO WITH THIS?
WELL, HERE'S WHAT
I HAVE TO DO WITH IT‐‐
WHETHER YOU LIKE FUBU OR NOT,
I CREATED IT IN THE BASEMENT,
AND EVERYBODY
ON THE DAMN PLANET KNOWS IT.
THAT'S EVERYBODY'S STORY HERE.
EVERYBODY HAS THAT STORY.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT YOU DID.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I HAVE BRANDED A STINKING
PAIR OF JEANS GLOBALLY,
AND I WILL DO THAT
WITH THE BROOM.
YOU SEE, THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
THE BROOM AND THE CLOTHING HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH EACH OTHER.
YOU SEE? HE'S NOT
EVEN LETTING ME SPEAK.
IMAGINE WHAT
HE'S GONNA DO TO YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU BRINGING
TO THE TABLE, DAYMOND?
I'M BRINGING $75,000.
FOR WHAT?
I'M BRINGING $75,000 FOR 33%,
BUT WE'LL CREATE
AN ENTIRE COMPANY.
FOR THE RECORD,
I'M DEFINITELY OUT.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY.
'CAUSE I DON'T SEE YOU
AS THE KIND OF GUY
WHO COULD GO THROUGH
A FINISH LINE, HONEST TO GOD.
(Harrington) I'M GONNA
GIVE AN OFFER.
YOU CAME IN ASKING
FOR $40,000, 25%.
I'M GONNA BUMP YOUR $40,000
A LITTLE BIT,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA GO TO $75,000
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
MY $50,000 OFFER FOR 25%
IS GONNA BE YOUR BEST DEAL.
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA MAKE
MILLIONS MORE OVER TIME,
BECAUSE THIS HAS TO GO ON
TELEVISION, AND YOU KNOW THAT.
DO YOU AGREE WITH ME?
I AGREE THAT IT HAS
TO GO ON TELEVISION.
OKAY, SO WE GOTTA START
WITH TV‐‐
BUT YOU NEED A LICENSE
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
YOU DEFINITELY NEED THIS BROOM.
THIS BROOM SPEAKS
EVERY LANGUAGE ON EARTH.
SURE.
EVERY KID SPILLS CRAP ON
THE FLOOR ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
SO LET'S THINK BIG. YOU NEED ME
TO THINK BIG. STOP THINKING SO‐‐
SHANE, REMEMBER
WHO'S SAYING THIS TO YOU.
BARBARA, IF YOU‐‐BARBARA.
THIS GUY'S A SHARK.
THEY ALL ARE.
YOU BETTER SLOW DOWN AND THINK.
YOU'RE A NICE GUY.
♪♪♪
ONE SHARK IS OUT,
BUT THE OTHERS ARE
IN A FEEDING FRENZY
OVER SHANE'S SweepEasy.
YOU BETTER SLOW DOWN AND THINK.
YOU'RE A NICE GUY.
LET ME FINISH WITH THIS‐‐
I DON'T WANT TO GO TO WAR
WITH YOU, MY FRIEND. YOU BRING
SOME VALUE TO THE TABLE,
AND YOU'RE THE TV GUY I DO KNOW.
LET'S GO 50/50. LET'S GO‐‐
GO AND CALL YOUR WIFE.
BARBARA,
IF YOU SCREW THIS UP FOR ME,
I'M GONNA SPANK YOU
LIKE A BABY SEAL.
NOW LISTEN, LET'S GET BACK
TO BUSINESS HERE. 50/50, KEVIN.
LET'S STOP FIGHTING 'CAUSE
I'M GONNA WIN THIS FIGHT
IF WE START IT.
YOU KNOW, KEVIN,
I‐I RESPECT YOU,
BUT THIS IS A PRODUCT I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL,
BECAUSE SEE, I WANT TO PUT HIM
AS THE FACE OF THIS PRODUCT.
DON'T LET
THAT VANITY THING WORK.
DON'T LET THAT WORK ON YOU.
YOU‐‐NO. YOU'RE GONNA BE THE GUY
ON THE SHOPPING CHANNELS.
YOU'RE GONNA‐‐YOUR FACE
COULD BE ON THE BOX,
SELLING THIS PRODUCT.
YOU CAN DO GREAT.
UGH, THAT'S SO HOLLYWOOD.
DON'T LET HIM PLAY THAT CARD.
(laughs)
I DON'T NEED ANY PARTNERS
ON THIS DEAL, OKAY?
SHANE, I'M WITH KEVIN. I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA NEED MORE MONEY.
I'D LIKE TO COME IN
ON THE LICENSING DEAL,
'CAUSE I THINK THAT IS THE ONLY
ROUTE THAT MAKES SENSE TO ME.
I'LL PUT UP ANOTHER $40,000
FOR THAT SAME 20%.
$80,000 FOR 20%?
YEAH.
LET'S LIFT IT TO 25%.
OKAY. SO $80,000 FOR 25%,
BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA NEED MORE CASH.
LIFE IS VERY SIMPLE.
TWO GUYS WANT TO BUILD BROOMS.
TWO GUYS WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
SHANE, SHANE, YOU KNOW WHAT? WE
UNDERSTAND PRODUCT, AND WE WILL
GET ALSO LICENSING ONCE
WE GET TO A COMFORTABLE LEVEL.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
LET'S DO SOMETHING.
$80,000
FOR 25% OF THE COMPANY?
CORRECT.
$80,000, 25% OF THE COMPANY.
HE DOES THE INFOMERCIALS,
I DO PRODUCT TO STORES,
WE HELP BUILD A BRAND ITSELF.
SHANE, I WANT‐‐
I WANT AN ANSWER.
I'M GONNA CALL MY WIFE.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOUR WIFE.
YOU WANT TO TALK TO MY WIFE?
YEAH. GET HER ON THE PHONE.
I WANT TO TALK TO HER.
I'M ACTUALLY THE ONE WHO WEARS
THE PANTS IN THE FAMILY,
AND SHE'LL TELL YOU THAT.
I GET THAT, BUT I'M NOT‐‐
I'M NOT SURE‐‐
YOU SEE HOW
HE'S INSULTING YOU ALREADY?
JUST PULL THE CORD
ON THESE TWO GUYS.
SHANE, I THINK YOU NEED TO MAKE
A DECISION RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW...
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA SAY
DIFFERENT TO MY WIFE?
LET'S‐‐I WANT TO TALK TO HER.
WELL...
LET'S TALK TO HER.
YOU KNOW, TALK IS CHEAP.
THAT'S THE BEAUTIFUL THING
ABOUT IT. LET'S TALK.
(Daymond) SHANE, LISTEN.
I'M STARTING...
WE HAVE ANOTHER MINUTE. SHANE,
LET'S HAVE A MINUTE. SILENCE.
ONE SECOND, KEVIN.
I'M STARTING TO RECONSIDER.
I‐I MAY RECONSIDER THE OFFER.
YOU KNOW WHY HE'S WORRIED?
BECAUSE IN THE BACK
OF YOUR MIND, SEAN...
AND SCRAPE HIM OFF OF THAT THING
RIGHT THERE RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING HERE. YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOMETHING HERE IN THIS LICENSE
DEAL YOU SHOULD CONSIDER.
IT'S A MUCH BIGGER VISION,
YOU BECOME MUCH WEALTHIER,
AND IT HAPPENS FASTER.
KEVIN, YOU'RE REALLY
EMBARRASSING YOURSELF RIGHT NOW.
STAY HERE. I'LL BE BACK
TO YOU IN A MINUTE.
HE WALKS OUT, I'M WITHDRAWING.
(Robert) SHANE, BE A MAN,
FOR GODS SAKE.
OKAY, WELL, SURE.
I‐I'M NEGOTIATING, ROBERT.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT
I FEEL LIKE I'M DOING.
I'M TRYING TO FIND WHAT'S BEST
FOR MY FAMILY AND FOR ME, SO...
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT HIM, BUT I'VE
JUST REDUCED MY $40,000 TO‐‐
LISTEN. I'VE JUST REDUCED
MY $40,000 TO $30,000,
SO NOW MY DEAL IS $70,000.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO RETAIN
THAT OFFER, AND I‐‐
IF YOU WILL GO BACK
TO YOUR ORIGINAL OFFER,
I'M GONNA‐‐I'M GONNA SAY
THAT I WANNA WORK WITH YOU.
RIGHT NOW?
YES.
(O'Leary) ALL RIGHT.
NOW I'M IN FOR THE $80,000
WITH YOU, DAYMOND.
RIGHT‐‐I'M GONNA‐‐
LET'S DO IT RIGHT NOW. DEAL.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
GOOD JOB.
(Barbara) GOOD DECISION.
THANK YOU, MAN.
(Shane) I KNEW YOU WERE THE MAN.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
DEAD MAN SWEEPING.
(laughs)
MAYBE WE LET THEM HAVE CANADA.
NO, WE'LL SEND 'EM SOME BROOMS.
WE'LL SEND 'EM SOME BROOMS.
TO HAVE THEM BE THAT EXCITED
ABOUT MY PRODUCT, IT FELT GOOD,
AND I'LL‐‐IT'LL ALLOW MY WIFE
TO STAY HOME WITH THE KIDS.
SO FOR THAT, I AM
TRULY BLESSED AND EXCITED.